alright dot see so nice to see you
thanks for coming up all the way from
Irvine to do the podcast this is a long
time in the making so I'm delighted to
talk to you today thank you very much
for having me yeah easy drive we'll see
how the way home but I know it might be
a little bit different going back but
you're here now and I'm gonna hold you
prisoner so cool so many things to talk
about but I think the most kind of top
of mind thing is this anti dairy ad that
you worked on with a bunch of other
Olympic athletes that was intended to
air during the closing ceremonies of
Pyeongchang so tell me a little bit
about that yeah so well the campaign
itself is called switch for good and the
you know kind of the inspiration for me
was I was just sitting on the couch
watching Olympic Trials like probably
you know two and a half months ago now
and the milk Life ad came on the dairy
board is a sponsor of the US Olympic
Committee and it says nine out of ten
Olympians grew up drinking milk which is
probably true because there's probably
nine out of ten people sorts of things
like so did nine out of ten serial
killers I mean you know clearly that's
just wildly misleading in terms of what
you drink when you're growing up has
anything to do with whether you're gonna
become an Olympian or not and then it
says that milk has natural proteins as
if there's any other kinds and balanced
nutrition in that and my blood just
started boiling I mean I just thought
that just for truths sake alone we have
to answer this this isn't truthful
advertising well right welcome to
advertising 101 but it just it just yeah
man it made my heart hurt and it made me
mad and I I just I started thinking okay
what how do we answer this in a really
intelligent backed up by science way
with a group of Olympians because that's
the best way to answer it who are her
telling the truth and have really
interesting stories to tell about their
dairy-free lifestyles so we just we went
to work and we whipped this puppy
together a really short period of time
and Louie you got Louis involved right
so he directed it he did yes yes Luke
the CEO said the director of the code so
huh yeah that was just I had worked with
him on the game-changers so I knew him
and was used to his style and his
directing style but he's uh yeah he's
mesmerizing to be in action with yeah
yeah it's cool so I saw it it's on
YouTube ad week picked it up there was a
lot of press around it and I know you
did like a Twitter chat the other night
that I chimed in on for a moment and I
shared that on my social media and it's
cool because when you think about the
power of the dairy Lobby on the
consciousness of the average consumer
it's it's kind of astonishing I mean
it's sort of diabolically genius the way
they've been able to infiltrate their
message across the board in public
institutions I mean there's posters in
public high schools that say milk does a
body good with guys bench-pressing and
milk mustaches and then they get
involved in the sports community by
sponsoring at a very high level things
like the Olympics I know there are a
title sponsor of I believe Ironman I
think or triathlon yeah they're very
integrated into the endurance community
and they've done an amazing job of
sponsoring athletes to get behind this
and so if you follow many an athlete on
Instagram you'll see them doing ads for
chocolate milk which has been they sort
of figured out a way to position as some
kind of athletic recovery boosting
elixir which is kind of insane and I
don't begrudge these athletes who are
trying to make a living you know just
trying to pay their bills who get
involved with this but when you kind of
stand back and look at it from 10,000
feet you're like what's going on here
yeah well I mean other Olympic sponsors
are McDonald's and Coca Cola so you know
follow the dollar bills
ever have to do have you been in it
you've probably been to Colorado Springs
right to the training center yeah yeah I
was there I couldn't believe what I
think this past year I saw a news piece
about they've gotten much better with
the food that they're serving it's a bit
better kind of been back since I was
treasurer now two years ago maybe
there's an actual entire McDonald's
restaurant inside of the eating facility
in the athletes village mm-hmm and it's
free right it's free for us yes yeah and
I mean sadly the entire Eastern Bloc is
in line because it's free McDonald's
we're like Oh gross or you know we have
McDonald's but in it's cheap here but
it's it's this it's the saddest thing
you've ever seen just that just that
total mind bender on you know you're at
the Olympics I mean you're pretty sure
that all these Ferraris lined up to put
sludge into their engines nastiest yeah
yeah it's so crazy all right so this PSA
so tell me about the impact of this like
that what happened here
yeah well say the least so we're just 48
hours in as of today media wise so far
we have we're at like 25 million
impressions and in 48 hours 35,000 views
on YouTube so we're going well off broad
broadcast right broad perhaps television
but we had a bit of the snafu the the
night that it was supposed to air on
closing ceremonies at 7:15 that the USOC
was able to get it pulled from NBC
because they're a client of nbc's and
follow the dollar bills again because
they said it was a direct attack on one
of their sponsors mm-hmm and there was
an olympic IP issue that they saw in the
final card of the of the commercial so
that's that is what it is
yeah it's not surprising right I mean
I'm sure you could foreseen this right
once they get wise to what's going on
like they're their bottom lines being
threatened by this it's an it's in
conflict with their leading sponsor or a
lead
sponsor but the good news is there's
something called the Internet you know
and there's a there's a there's a way to
still get the message out and I think it
is getting out so I think it's cool it's
a first stab at counter programming and
there's a story in and of itself the
fact that it got pulled can create a new
story they can create additional
interest in what you're trying to yeah
it's just like you know the the early
years of tobacco as they went along you
know people started realizing something
was being hidden from them and people
get pissed when they realize like their
something's being hidden in someone's
life did you get were you on the
receiving end of a little backlash oh no
no not yet no it's been really positive
but what I'm saying is is now that we're
bringing forward how dangerous dairy is
and that it's not a health food it is
not a health food like they are saying
it is and we have many of these really
inspires inspiring anecdotal stories and
a lot of science backing it up people
the general public as they look deeper
because they have something like the
internet like you said they're gonna
start looking deeper and they're gonna
start realizing that they've been lied
to that dairy is a health food and it
makes for strong bones and that it's
good for you and that and people aren't
gonna like that so that's good
yeah that is good that is good so the
athletes you it you got rebecca soni is
a friend yeah Kendrick Farris yes is in
the spot yeah yeah those two are both
just amazing I love their individual
stories
Seba Johnson who is um the first
african-american ski racer in in history
also the youngest ski racer ever
she is vegan since birth so she's never
had a glass of milk and in her ski
racing career she never broke about mmm
and I don't even know his ski racer that
hasn't broke yeah I would imagine she
did after her ski racing career and a
very bad accident but in her ski racing
career she's she's never never broke a
bone Kara Lange who's a Canadian soccer
player and a mom she's got a great story
Malachi Davis who's a sprinter was a
sprinter for Great Britain 2004 uh-huh
and Kendrick is a weightlifter yes
Olympic weightlifter I can't remember
did he met
no but he was seven he was so he did
quite well he was the only u.s. male
weightlifter to qualify for Rio so he
was the only one that went though and I
people don't really realize I don't
think that you countries have to qualify
their spot for Olympic Games and then
the country themselves the coaches
picked who will fill that spot which is
not always the person that qualifies the
spot in it is in weightlifting for him
but in other sports which is lots of
layers of politics that people don't
necessarily realize goes on yeah but you
have to qualify the spot it's not like
just cuz you know you're a country a big
country that you just you know
automatically go to the Olympics it's
not the way it works right right right
got it
all right cool well let's let's take it
back I mean there's so many layers to
your story it's an amazing story I mean
you're you're quite an unlikely Olympian
in some regards you know I mean you were
that was not the trajectory that you
were headed on as a young person and
most people who end up at the Olympics
are people who've been harboring that
dream you know since they were an infant
just dreaming of being on that podium
but you were living a very different
life as a young person just a wee bit a
little bit yeah
yeah I didn't I mean you did sports
right you did you wrote Crewe in college
I did for like a year until it was like
messing up my party scene cuz you get up
at 4:30 in the morning but and I did I
grew up in Kentucky so I grew up riding
horses
but you know the horse is the athlete
not you but I did grow up in like a
competitive I had a competitive nature
about me and I you know competed in
Saddlebred horse pride riding from a
young age so I think I had that part of
me and my emotions in my mind that you
know really loved the competition aspect
but then I through high school in
college it just kind of got a got away
from it and definitely went wayward I
mean it was it was a it was a deep dive
into the underbelly of New York City in
the modern world
Miller with that underbelly so let's
let's explore that a little bit I mean
you know something that I can relate to
in your story is you're in college
you're an athlete and at some point the
veneer fades with the early morning
workouts and all of that and there's the
social partying life that kind of
and hers and starts to take center stage
so I I'm projecting on you but I'm
presuming that at some point in college
this is what was that this is what was
happening yeah yeah it was it was it was
I was kind of living two lives because I
I got okay grades in high school but I
really really loved college because
you're finally you know learning what
you're free but in in school in the
actual classes like you're doing what
you're interested in right right so
you're not so I I was getting really
great rate great grades and studying
really hard and loving my classes and
then at the same time just that part of
me that I think felt like I you know
hadn't been able to be let out of my
shell before was had the ability to do
that in a way like like never before
which you know almost every single
person in Chicago just experienced that
it's not like that's a rare findings I
mean growing up were you like what kind
of an environment was your family
situation I grew up in a pretty
traditional like Midwest solid family
like great just ya know it wasn't like
you're rebelling against your parents no
no I know that we are we were close were
still close that yeah that time was
friggin rough for them
especially as I got more and more
towards my deathbed when I got really
really sick with anorexia because by
that point I was you know 20 21 I'm not
they don't have any control right I'm
not ten there was really nothing they
could do they tried some interventions
that weren't very unsuccessful so yeah
it was um it was it was really tough for
them mm-hmm well addiction alcoholism
you know these sobriety recovery these
are you know constant themes of my
podcast and I've had plenty of people
come in and share their experience
strength and hope in this regard but
I've never had anybody on to share about
eating disorders and there's been a lot
of people who've been wanting me to
explore this topic this subject matter
on the show so I'm really glad to have
you here because I think your story is
very powerful and
and what you what you had to face and
kind of how dark it got and how you
overcame it is pretty empowering so
where does it where does that begin
where does the dysfunctional
relationship with food start in it start
to enter your life well it starts with a
dysfunctional relationship with yourself
you said you've had a lot of people on
that have had drug addiction stuck
suffered from alcohol alcoholism and
alcohol abuse and it's it's really not
too dissimilar it is a clinically
recognized disease that is an illness
and it's really whatever most of those
people probably told you about some kind
of issue that they were grappling with
and then they stride a drug or they
drank too much and they realized that
they could you know escape or fall into
and you know ulterior universe and and
and leave that pain that they were in
eating disorders really exactly the same
route mm-hmm I was in a significant
amount of pain in my life in confusion
and fear
part of it was stemming from I felt like
a real lack of control as I was
graduating college I had majored in
journalism and thought I wanted to go
into hard news and realized at the very
end of college in my internship that I
hated it and and that was one of the
first times I recognized how much
control big business has over everything
that we do it had a lot of control over
news this is Philadelphia KYW and it was
like wow I don't want to do this you
know it's gonna it's control the whole
time and so I was freaking out that I
what what I had just studied and majored
in in college like what was I gonna do
with my life so I I started to it just
very much started kind of slowly in the
beginning where I just started to assert
some control over my food restriction
because it's really really hard to
starve yourself I mean you know and that
made me feel powerful and power
empowered one thing that you can control
absolutely and you can write you you you
do you have the ultimate control over
what what goes in and and and and you're
eating it sounds like kind of you know
almost meaningless or trivial but it
really started to make me feel like I
had
everything under control so how old were
you at this time 1919 yeah and is there
kind of a euphoria that's associated
with that like in the same way that you
get a hit from absolutely yeah it's
better because I did a lot of cocaine
it's it it there yeah and there's
there's some there's some aspects of
this that in my life I've been a little
careful with talking about because
anybody that is in the midst of an Evan
eating disorder in the throes of the
suffering just as I did will tend to use
some of these ideas that I'm presenting
to fuel so I like to be kind of careful
with the the celebrating it if you will
in a way where yet yeah I was a high yes
it's when when you're when you're
starving yourself you there you hit a
point where you feel like you're on a
substance and you're kind of floaty and
very very I mean your brain isn't
working I mean you know your every every
aspect every organ is being starved so
things starts to shut down at the
towards the end and that what was what
was happening to me your body starts to
eat its own organs I mean you know it
will do anything to stay alive so your
brain is an organ but I think it's
important to acknowledge and the fact
that you know it if it didn't work for a
while you wouldn't keep doing it like it
works until it stops working right so
one of the first sort of things to
confront is just acceptance or
acknowledgement of the fact that it was
doing something for you right and that's
what allows you to continue or to dive
deeper into it yeah I don't want to
trigger anyone either
but I think like developing an
understanding of how powerful it is and
how it really did give you a sense of
control you know in you know in the
midst of this you know feeling of
powerlessness that you were experiencing
is I think is important to recognize
yeah no you're right and and then
conversely you know discussing the the
true power that comes with freedom
and being well is you know that that
there there is no comparison from now to
then as far as the actual power that I
feel in my life now but that is you know
it's a it's a dark scary place that you
keep chasing just like you do a drug
because you want that feeling again so
it's so it's very that's what again
comes more and more difficult to access
that feeling right in the same way that
you become tolerant to a drug yeah well
you just start eating less and less
right so you're you're chasing it and
then you get to the point where
obviously if you're not eating anything
then then you're you know you're
hospitalized and then you know but yeah
you you do chase all the way until where
you're it says you're at zero calories
yeah so this begins in the early stages
of you sort of attempting to pursue a
career in journalism but at some point
modeling enters and and it's almost like
a perfect storm this confluence of the
New York modeling world
you know converging with eating
disorders and you know this fast-paced
lifestyle that's a perfect recipe to
really you know dismantle you yeah no
doubt I mean there wasn't any aspect of
the modeling world that was necessarily
fueling it you know I really had my own
deep-seated reasons and was really
pretty far into my eating disorder by
the time that I was modeling in New York
but I had just started modeling in the
late part of college in Philadelphia and
and then moved to New York with an
agency it was just like okay well you
know for me it was like well this is
interesting for a while I can will
travel some and you know is that it just
was you know happening but it wasn't
anything that was you know
single-handedly fueling me to get
skinnier and I didn't really have any
kind of you know kind of outwardly
connections with what I looked like or
if there was fat here or there or if my
butt was big or not it wasn't so many
people think that it's really just an
exterior view of yourself and you know
you have body dysmorphic disorder you
know most people do I probably
but it wasn't it wasn't outward-facing
at all for me it was just the could
continuing to assert this control that's
interesting because I would imagine that
you were surrounded by plenty of
enablers who are saying look you got to
get skinnier if you want to book this
job or what have you and surrounded by a
community of people you know other
models who are trying to be as skinny as
possible right yeah yeah one thing about
that I found in in in the modeling
industry I mostly did I'm not that
photogenic and mostly did runway is that
and so especially the runway models
they're complete freaks of nature yes
there's those that have eating disorders
and are starving themselves and you know
I clearly we've heard those stories but
by and large these people are they come
out of the womb that way they're there
their whole makeup it doesn't make any
sense they eat whatever they want to eat
whenever they want to eat it they eat at
McDonald's all the time and they just
look like that this bizarre yes it's
wildly frustrating but it's true you
know they're not all just not eating
there many many many of them that I
would travel with is like they had very
normal eating then they ate crap which
wasn't great but and it just it wouldn't
show up anywhere but nothing shows up
anywhere on you and you're 16 or 17 or
18 19 and and are you keeping this a
secret like living this yeah I've it you
know double life where you're hiding all
of this kind of behavior and it was it
was a bulimia also or towards the end it
was bulimia yeah well you kind of your
body just well really I guess milk it's
more your mind sort of snaps into this
realization that you're starving and but
then you eat and then you can't deal
with that what that feels like and looks
like and is so yeah and maybe I think it
would be instructive for somebody who's
unfamiliar with this or maybe somebody
who's listening who has somebody in
their life who suffers or is you know
has suffered from this
- maybe bust a few myths like what do
people misunderstand or not get about
what this disorder is all about yeah
that's a great point like for parents
and and friends and family that question
I get at that
ask that question a lot and I think the
most the biggest myth is that it is a
you know exterior facing and that if you
talk about to the person you're too
skinny or you're looking skinny or in
your intellectual yeah or just even
using those terms as if you're looking
at the person as just the only thing
that's important about them as if is if
they're skinny or fat so completely
removing that rhetoric and talking to
them from a place of love and concern
about their their health right and their
and just their ability to be in society
and in the world and and what their
talents are so remove that language and
also so many people every person really
that doesn't understand an eating
disorder is just like Lucy can you just
eat a cheeseburger
yeah like just eat a cheeseburger will
be better it'll be so much better if you
just do that because we have to eat food
every day all day long so unlike drugs
or alcohol where you do have to just
completely remove that right you you
know in three hours you have to eat in
order because you have yeah completely
you know reframe your relationship with
this thing that you need to survive yes
so if family members you know you have
that said to you you know if you just
can you just eat a little something so
that is another thing that people need
to dive in and learn a bit more about
what eating disorders actually are and
and come to the person with the place of
love and not mention how they look and
not mention what they're eating that's
not what's going on really think of it
maybe as a disease like and alcoholism
and and that helps people to reframe the
reference because then they understand
they understand alcoholism most people
like okay I get that that's but in they
go oh that's the same type of psychology
then it helps them to frame speaking to
a friend or family about their eating
disorder yeah it's a very interesting
and bizarre psychological framework
because you know look just from my own
experience as a recovering alcoholic
for many years I knew I was an alcoholic
and I knew what I was doing was
destroying my life I was powerless to
change it but I had the self-awareness
and I would imagine yourself for
somebody who's struggling with an eating
disorder has some version of that
self-awareness along the way but there's
this weird twist which is the body
dysmorphia and the bizarre very strange
psychological you know twist that comes
with that which is you're looking in the
mirror and you're you're what's being
reflected back to you is not reality
like your perception of what you look
like is so twisted and divorced from
what is actually true that is that is
like very hard for somebody to relate to
or understand yeah it is I think you
know it in your subconscious I think
that you are a bit aware of you know
it's like I would have like moments of
clarity where it was like oh yeah I'm
really sick this is really bad this is
not like wire you know now these pants
aren't even fitting you know is it like
oh what happened that was just like a
week ago but then you sort of snap out
of that and you're in you're back into
your then reality that you're that
everything's fine and you don't you
don't really think that you're sick from
anything I mean it most of the time it's
like you know know that this is normal
this is fueling me this is this is what
I want it to be and and for me again it
wasn't like wasn't connected to the
mirror for me
it went from a feeling of wanting to be
in control to a feeling of I wanted to
disappear from the planet I didn't want
anyone looking at me I didn't want any
attention I didn't want people talking
about me or how I looked cuz being in
the modeling industry that would be you
know a common conversation right I got
to where I wanted to get so small that I
would disappear off the the planet well
a couple observations about that first
of all you're in a profession that is
the antithesis of that and ironically
the more you shrink the more attention
you're drawing for yourself out of
concern from others right like yeah but
not on the street right because you're
not you're you know you you get wildly
an
attractive I mean my hair was turning
gray it was falling out my teeth were
turning black like you get pretty gnarly
there towards you know it well whatever
you're gonna get a different kind of
attention we're gonna look at you
strange on the street oh yeah or they
just don't notice I mean I had a lot of
it like people just started stopped
noticing I I didn't like being gawked at
by whatever the construction worker in
New York City or whatever they were
doing and they're you know and I I
started feeling like I wanted to
disappear and it was a way to disappear
people stopped noticing me and it worked
did you do that thing where you look in
the mirror and you pinch your skin and
think of that that's fat that has to be
lost when you're you didn't know it
that's a common thing though right I
think it's less common than we than we
think it is I mean I you know yes some
people it's it's just a direct relation
to you know what they're looking at in
the mirror but if the people that are
pinching their skin and going I have to
get rid of that they're there they're
dealing with a lot of inner pain a lot
of self-hatred right and beating
themselves up for so many more reasons
than just that fold of skin that they're
pinching right it's got to be a very
painful lonely place to be in I would
imagine yeah just like you I mean you
know that you know that space yeah it's
um it is and you thrive off of it for a
while until you don't yeah it has its
own energy mm-hmm so what's the word
where do you hit bottom with this I mean
you get down to like 90 pounds a hundred
pounds or something like that yeah I got
I got below that um I tried to kill
myself so that was a that was a ran out
in traffic on the 76 freeway the middle
of the night when that happened 20 22 I
guess it was 21 22 night night in New
York no no no I was back in Philly I
went back and forth for a while and you
know obviously it didn't work yeah so
but that was rock bottom for me yeah so
so how do you then begin to pick up the
pieces I mean what what is the what is
the process of addressing this look like
for you um you know I had this this uh
this moment where I I really clearly
remember seeing a fork in the road I
knew that if I kept going that I was
gonna die from this and I was going to
get so deep down that road that I wasn't
be able to pull back out and it was
gonna take my life and that was a
sobering moment of what who would would
do that to the few people I had in my
life
that really loved and cared for me at
that period of time and I always say to
people you know yes eventual recovery
have to has to come from within but it
doesn't necessarily have to be that
first catalyst and for me it was it was
my family I thought I can't die like
that's so that's so lame on my part for
them is so wildly selfish so I know I'm
not gonna go get better but I'm gonna do
I'm gonna try a little bit because I
have to at least show them that I tried
and then if I die hopefully they won't
be as sad be you know you think of the
craziest right when you but that's
what I was thinking I mean just gonna
show them some effort so I I started
trying to get better and that sense of
self-hatred that that feeling that that
desire to disappear like yeah where do
you think that comes from I mean growing
up with parents that love you it's not
like oh I was a beaut you know I think
that's another thing people struggle
with struggle with really understanding
like that well there must have been some
incidents in your childhood or something
like that it doesn't necessarily have to
be connected to something no 30 30 to 35
percent of eating disorder sufferers had
it was a severe abuse in their early
childhood years so it's that's extremely
that's a real thing but it's not
necessarily determinative yet right
right but I mean that's it is communist
but yeah so there and there there was
there was none of that in in in my life
at all and I don't you know I think some
of it has to do with just the you know
the makeup of who we are I'm an extreme
introvert which no one believes but III
am and I to this day that is hard to
believe I know
but if you really understand you know
introversion extroversion you know it's
not just like oh I don't like to talk or
something I've so many charismatic
people that come on this podcast and
explain to me how they're so introverted
and I always have the same reaction
right but it's not with charisma right
it's how we kind of recharge but I I I
think that I just um to this day I
really I would like to just live out in
the middle of nowhere on a farm with
like 200 animals and never speak or see
anyone ever again like I have a deep
desire for that but I know that that's
not how I'm gonna save any animals so
starting with alcoholics to that desire
to isolate you know to cut yourself off
yeah so I think that's it was my
personality that was just coming through
back then as it does now but I'm able to
say okay well no you're gonna you're
making a conscious decision to not go
you know isolate because I don't think I
can do much good if I isolate but but
but back then that was you know I think
that's really more what it what it was
mm-hmm and so did your parent I mean
your parents must have been terrified
terrified yeah I think they're trying to
help you beyond yeah and they're doing
interventions my mom flew to
Philadelphia to do one intervention that
I distinctly remember and I ended up I
don't have very many regrets in my life
this is one of them I took her to the
Philadelphia Airport I don't even think
she had a ticket like I just didn't want
any of this to be happening and I
literally physically threw my mother out
on the street corner at the airport like
what who does that
that's the power of that's that's
addiction and a nutshell it's like it's
not you it's not you know it's it's a
behave it's a domotic behavior that's
being driven by this disease that's
compelling you in a way that transcends
you know who you fundamentally are as a
human being yeah you're at a complete
outer-body I was so sick by then it is
demonic and it is completely out her
body like I now it feels like that was
another human being but I can't relate
to and and it's a you know and she still
loves me
my mom you know that that's also that
took a long time to process through of
why she would would still she just kept
coming back she's kept loving hard
mm-hmm
so you get to this point after this you
know sort of failed suicide attempt
where you have the willingness to you
know finally accept help so what does
that help look like well it wasn't great
at the beginning because I was you know
I had been like in and out of of you
know like rehab facilities and in group
facilities and things like that early on
that I didn't you know was not
successful I didn't want to be there but
I went through a few therapists that I
didn't connect with I guess should just
say you know it wasn't the right wasn't
wasn't the right we're gonna be the
right people so I had moved out to LA by
this point I was doing production for
commercials and music videos back when I
was working and so we came out from the
East Coast to do a three week job here
in LA and it was like the middle of
January and I was like is this 78 sunny
thing like is this is this normal there
never is like oh yeah it's always like
this and it's like okay so I just moved
I was like this is insane and I I hate
cold weather and and really just living
in New York City anyway so I moved out
and I just came upon like a little teeny
tiny ad in a newspaper in a coffee shop
that there was going to be a speaker on
fear in the basement of a Borders
bookstore mmm I mean random that is yeah
and went down to listen to her speak and
I just went up to her afterwards and I
said I you know can can you help me she
was phenomenal she was a shrink
mmm-hmm yeah yeah she does she does a
lot of fear-based work was very busy
after 9/11 when nobody would go on a
plane there but a lot of what was inside
of me was was fear really right
realize that and you and you learn that
at the at the end of it all so we got to
work and she was yeah she blew my mind
what's interesting about that is that
you're you're the one who made the
decision right it was it was her own
willingness and impetus to like seek
this person out and and pursue her as
opposed to somebody trying to compel you
to do that yep yeah yeah that's it you
can't manufacture when you were already
yeah and that's the hardest part for for
families of someone who's subbing for an
eating disorder I do have free
mentorship program so I just you know
I've walked down the road with a lot of
eating disorder sufferers just as
somebody who's been in their shoes and
encouraged and I get a lot of thumb
outreach from friends and family that
are just they're just so desperate and
and and it's so hard for them to just
really let it sink in that they can't do
anything until the person's ready that's
with everything that's whatever it's
alcohol at all and it's just
but it's so in-your-face on addiction
yeah so because you can just see it it's
like yeah you cannot compel somebody to
be willing they have to be willing
themselves they've got to walk this path
until they're ready and until they're
ready it's not going to stick and that's
a sense of powerlessness that the loved
one of the addict has to embrace and
that's a very difficult thing
mm-hmm your parents had to go through
that you know it's it's an awful place
to be because you can see that the
healthy path forward so clearly and it's
so confounding and confusing and painful
to watch us somebody's self destructs
right in front of you yeah and you know
what the answer is I know I know
yeah so you find this person and what
was it about her that worked for you
like what was her process yeah unpack
this she put me to work the every other
therapists and psychologists that I had
seen before we you know would sit in the
chair opposite me with their yellow
legal pad and they're you know cool pen
and would just be writing a lot and okay
uh-huh
well what let's dip dive deeper into
that okay well and they're writing I'm
like you're writing you know and and
this therapist her name is Chris from
almost the third time I saw her I mean
she's been a couple of obsessions like
trying to you know hear my story right
and she put me to work
and I I I'm very coachable I like to
work and I like I like tools and I like
steps and I like ways of doing things
and she was very action-oriented nobody
that early especially in my therapy had
said okay this is that this is your work
she was her basis was was was meditation
therapy so putting me to work would look
things like okay when you are at this
point I'm deep into the bulimia because
we're you know we're towards the end and
so so she said okay when you are having
the urge you're gonna go for first of
all you're gonna go to the store and
you're gonna buy little blue dots and
sticky papers that you can you know
little sticky blue dots from the drug
store and you're gonna place them on
your trigger areas and so you'd say the
refrigerator is you know okay a trigger
you're gonna if you're gonna binge and
purge you see the blue dot you have 10 I
won't go into details but you had you
have to stop you have to do this very
specific 30-second meditation and it
would walk through a series of questions
that I had to ask myself an answer and
if you still wanted to to binge and this
would be the same thing with the blue
dot on the toilet if I was going to
purge you can go ahead and do it you
have complete freedom go ahead and binge
but first you fish you have to do this
work well you can imagine how it that
progressed you know I I was you know
sitting in front of the refrigerator
meditating for an hour before then I
would decide and then eventually you
decide I think I can I think I cannot do
that today
well how does Amaro's gonna go but for
today so that's just an you know it's
just one example of all the different
types of was their work in tools like a
visualization or like a like
mantra based not mantra but like some
sort of thing that you would tell
yourself like a story no it was more it
was more accessing what I was feeling
which I never accessed before cuz that's
what you do as an addict right whether
it's it's it's drugs or an eating
disorder which we're you know both
poisons for me you're all you're doing
that to get a hide to not feel what
you're actually feeling so it was
accessing first it was just accessing
where am I feeling anything is it in my
right finger tip of my pointer finger is
it in my foot is that in my gut is it in
my chest where do you where do you feel
it what does it look like what does it
feel like how big is it is it does it
feel sore does it feel sharp does it
feel you know painful what is it what
does it look like what does it feel like
so that was like at the beginning I you
know when I did that meditation with her
before I would have to do it on my own
I'm thinking this woman is cray-cray
like what you know because you're so
violently disconnected from yourself
when you start getting better when you
start this this work and to start to
connect with that was like it just it
just felt nutty in the beginning yeah
but that's the process of integrating
because yes the the fridge is the
trigger and you have the blue dot on the
fridge but the trigger isn't really the
fridge it's the emotions that the fridge
catalyze within yourselves and learning
what those are where they come from and
what they're about and what's behind
them is the process of rebuilding
yourself and recovering right yeah right
yeah and she that's powerful
yes she's remarkable is the first were
first one that that ever even went in
that in that direction and a lot of
times I would access painful different
types of anger and she had this this
anger stick that she had me made and it
was just a bath towel that we'd rolled
up to like a snake and put rubber bands
about two inches apart all the way down
the bath towel and I had this literal
like you you I would get on my knees and
slap
anger towel on the ground over and over
and over again I mean I'm god I don't
have any video of this to release that
anger that I couldn't figure out what to
do with I mean it was just brilliant
stuff in my opinion it was a completely
different person after releasing that
anger okay we got to put it somewhere
otherwise I'm gonna binge and purge
right or go out for the night and you
know do whatever yeah it was it was it
was amazing I still have the anger towel
use it I don't anymore
but what's cool about that is the
fundamental difference between you know
sort of traditional therapy of like well
let's just talk forever versus very
proactive behavior faced action based
you know tactile things that you can
actually do that will begin to shift
your awareness and create new neural
pathways and connect you with yourself
and and develop that self-awareness but
in a way that is actually propelling you
in a different direction because it's
behavior based I know it really is you I
mean we've all known people that have
been in therapy for like forever mm-hmm
and I'm just one person and this was
just my one experience and it sometimes
other types of therapy work for people
but sometimes I'm like ah man you know
it's like you you got you got to get
down you got to get dirty and gritty and
dive into you know really I would just
go insane if it was if I was like still
in therapy you know it you know you can
always access some of it I you know I've
done some you know emergency phone calls
to her throughout my life but but
because we did all of that super solid
work I never have one inkling of a fear
that I could ever go back into my eating
disorder again I always have like no I
did I did way too much work it's not
even possible and the emergency calls to
her that I've had in my life that were
you know other stressful situations we
were like done and dusted in one session
or two you know it was like oh yeah
right okay that okay you know you
because you're your memory comes back
and you you you you have the
tools they're embedded in you now you
don't lose them and it would just be for
her you know kind of redirecting okay go
back to this remember oh yeah yeah okay
I've got this which is just so cool it
wasn't like oh I got to go to 50 more
sessions now I'm just screwed up in my
life and yeah what's what's also
different or distinct from substance
abuse I mean you get sober
okay this is my sobriety date I've
crossed this line I don't go back I kind
of you know Achin stone like this is the
date that I got sober but like with
eating disorders it's it's it can't be
like that like because you're you're
recalibrating your relationship with
food and you have to be eating along the
way so I would imagine it was a more
graduated process of trying to you know
get on top of this thing right like so
how long did it take before you felt
like okay I'm getting a handle on it um
a little over two years I mean but
that's not it by the first section first
session I thought oh my gosh I think I'm
gonna get a handle on this but it took a
little over two years before I was a
hundred percent and I knew I would never
go back and I knew I was no it was
really really well and healed and this
is it wasn't even I got asked all the
time in my cycling career you know do
you think you're just replacing this
replacing the eating disorder with this
you know if your athleticism
and it was like no way it's not there's
no possibility that that I don't know if
something else will be a problem later
but it's not gonna be an eating disorder
yeah I get I get that a lot like oh well
you do these ultra Merrit it's like hell
you're just didn't you're just you just
shifted your addiction and I think for
me it's a little bit different I have to
like like I I want to dismiss it but
then I have to go am i you know I guess
probably on some level I am you know but
I'm doing it at healthier different who
we are as parts your personnel yeah it's
taking some aspect of who I am and
trying to channel it for self-betterment
and and the like there is I'm sure
there's an addictive aspect to it
but it's different because it's not
destroying my life it's improving my
life it could it could destroy my life
if I had a different kind of
relationship with that as it could for
you with cycling it could have no doubt
but once you have you
on that work you have a different you
have a different framework for it I
think yeah but it isn't it you know like
the you know perhaps this is good now we
can segue into the into the cycling I
would imagine initially like the
prospect because over-exercising is
symptomatic of an eating disorder did
you have an impulse early on like to
take that sort of manic addict energy
and channel it into something else that
wasn't necessarily food yeah well I had
severe over-exercise disorder with the
anorexia late night hours and the gym on
the Stairmaster you know it's like so
that was your early cycling career right
yeah although it wasn't a bike I never
for whatever reason I think I didn't
think it was gonna burn enough you know
it's like you gotta have the whole body
movement your Stairmaster running or the
elliptical I don't know yeah but when
when we finally got towards the end of
my therapy my therapist I think she knew
she knew me very well by that point and
she recognized that there was a you know
there was a competitor in there
somewhere and that ideally if I was able
to act out on that competitive nature
that would be the most healthy and she
also knew that that I would not consider
myself healed I told her this in the
beginning until I could move my body in
a healthy way again because I knew I'd
like to move my body and knew that about
myself but I was doing it very
unhealthful ii for so long in my eating
disorder so she knew that i had that
goal and so she said you know i i feel
like we're at the point where we're
really ready to kind of pick something
for you to be able to move your body in
a healthy way again but i want to just
completely detach from any sort of
negative connections you had with any
type of exercises so what's something
that you just really have never done
before and I said what about riding a
bike because that was not anything that
I had done in the eating disorder and I
had not written a bike since I was you
know you know 10 years old on the
banana seat bike in the flag in the
neighborhood
so she said perfect great it's super
interesting because it could have gone
the other way where look you know
exercise is a trigger for me so I'm just
gonna not I'm gonna avoid that for the
rest of my life because that could pull
me back into this downward spiral but I
think it takes courage to say no I need
to go back into exercise but I need to
figure out how to have a healthy
relationship with it yeah cuz you just I
just knew it wasn't that wasn't gonna be
often took me mm-hmm
you know and then and then then again
that's just that's not total healing if
I'm just you know deleting parts of
myself yeah it's still living in fear
and it's still being a prisoner to this
disease yes right so so you enter in so
crazy like this is just basically an
experiment to become a whole human being
not to like I'm gonna be a competitive
athlete like it's I mean first of all
how old were you at this point
I like experiment to be a whole human
being 26 26 okay so you get a bike yeah
you start pedaling around the
neighborhood yeah pretty much like
Griffith Park observatory I was like
that that's where I was and I got a bike
that was like a mountain bike but I got
slick tires put on it so I could ride on
the street so as you know bouncing
around with the shocks but I started
riding around Griffith Park observatory
and then all of a sudden you know I
noticed there's like these groups of
really fast people that would come by me
and I'm like oh I think I can stay with
them and then I kind of could and then
they were like what are you doing like
what you know cuz I just looked all
sorts of wrong right the clothes
everything and so um I met someone on on
those group rides that was gonna do the
California aids ride and I thought well
that's cool cuz I can like do something
good you know you have to Rae it back
then you had a race I'm a lot more now
but he had to raise $3,000 and I was
like well this is ninety six ninety
ninety eight when I did it so this was
97 and I thought oh my god that's so
much money how am i high write letters
to everybody I've ever met and raised
the money it's like I'm gonna do
something good and it went from Sanford
San Francisco to LA but it's the cycle
almost you know 700 miles because they
don't go direct
and that was that was I was like at the
front with the head guys and I'm still
on my mountain bike with the slick tires
and like the fourth day and they're like
what who are you what are you doing and
how long have you been riding a bike at
this point like just a matter of months
I mean just not any period of time at
all and I was that competitiveness like
I got to be up front I guess so I don't
you know I think too like I I mean I'd
like I used to like to suffer I don't
like to suffer as much as I used to but
I've always liked to suffer and and the
suffering that I went through in my
eating disorder was just so much more
massive than any suffering I was going
to ever experience on a bicycle so it
just didn't feel like much you know I
mean I knew I was suffering and it was
you know definitely an aspect to that
but it just it wasn't that bad and the
best part of the cycling was I knew the
suffering would end I mean I knew there
was a finish line I knew there was gonna
be tents and warm showers and yummy food
and you know it was gonna end so I was
like this is gonna last an hour or five
I'm not sure but but that ability to dig
that deep and suffer that hard was you
know it definitely was um trained quite
well in my eating disorder years for
sure use that yeah yeah yeah high pain
threshold yeah from psychic pain to
physical pain
yeah and physical pain and your eating
disorder that sure I mean yeah pretty
extreme uh-huh alright so you do the
aides ride I mean are the lights going
on like how is this are you thinking
mm-hmm no I'm thinking nothing and then
the guy I mean I just I'm like I don't
know that it's weird that I'm at the
front with these guys I don't know
anything you know maybe I'd they're just
nice guys that were I might I felt like
I was lip on pedals at least yeah yeah
yeah but mountain bike shoes so they're
not even hard sole so I'm losing some
watts through those puppies so we
finished the aides ride and a couple of
them were like have you ever raised some
like know if you ever thought I racing
I'm like know what rate rate what race
where are you we just did a race they're
like no this isn't a real race this is
like a play not to be on think oh I
thought it was a race could have told me
that day what I could have taken it easy
so they said I think you should try like
a race race you know you got to get like
a license with like USA Cycling and
you know where do I do that they're like
well here let's go on the internet they
literally bought my license for me and I
tried my first race and ya know that's
the rest is history and and this starts
to happen pretty quickly right it was
like two weeks you know like the next
week or something yeah it was like okay
you're gonna get a license and then my
first race was up in Monterey California
more like a road race a road race in the
pouring rain and as the most scared I've
ever been on a bicycle it's still to
this day it was absolutely treacherous
and I cuz I have no skills that's the
thing you know now I'm like 20 you know
whatever twenty seven and a half or
something you know what I mean and I
have zero skills and you're with people
who have been riding you know when the
women's peloton they don't start quite
as early as the men do but you know
they've been riding at least since high
school you know for sure and you know I
didn't grow up with any of that those
that I hand coordination those motor
skills the technical abilities you know
a lot of that is really you know the at
the high level it's it's pretty it's
intense the technicalities I mean it's
it's like you're you know centimetres
from each other's handlebars in packs of
150 climbing up the Alps descending I
mean you know we've all watched the tour
different like those are the descents
you're doing I had I had zero skills
zero ability to control my bike or be
safe or I mean it was it was not just
safe for yourself but safer everyone
else oh yeah yeah liability a complete
liability and I was treated as such for
quite a while in the women's peloton
uh-huh
so it wasn't like you enter your first
race and you win no I got like twelfth
or something in that yeah I was like a
calf or was it yeah absolutely
yeah all right but did it get its claws
in you like were you like oh man this is
this is gonna be my thing yeah I write
when I finish I remember going to the
van and trying to warm up it was
freezing and changing my clothes and
calling my mom and going that's the most
horrible experience I have ever had in
my life I want to die that was so dumb
we're going home and within hours
I was like where's the next race right
it could have been like I'm hanging it
up like that for me it was yeah yeah but
then you just realized that's bike
racing mm-hmm it's awful but you move up
pretty quickly right from calf or - cat
- and how long is this yes I moved up
from cat 40 cat 1 in in in less than a
year so it was again that's cool but I
was a liability still at this point
because I'm now a cat 1 and just scary
to be around in a criterium for sure and
by this point I've bought a bike that
some people will know is a soft ride so
it was those old triathlon bikes when
you're like Boing Boing Boing Boing and
I'm gonna crit and people are like you
have to get a bike that doesn't bounce
around like go through the corners and
warp speed though but where does the I
think I read somewhere I like that you
sort of said to somebody that you were a
professional cyclist before you were
even a professional cyclist I did so I
decided that if I was gonna do this I I
think I came from the age right I was
like I gotta get more miles on my legs
like these people I'm gonna be competing
against you know they have they've been
doing this a long time ago two more
miles man my leg so I lived in Venice so
I decided if I got a bike messenger job
in downtown LA then that would give me
almost 60 miles a day because it was 25
miles to ride there 25 back right then
he a messenger so I go downtown LA I get
a bike messenger job I'm the only girl
I'm the only one that doesn't smoke a
tremendous amount of pot all day long
Wow and so I did I did that and I
started to get those miles in my legs
and that was that that was that skill
probably like technical skills I started
a little bit like yeah the guys were
starting to teach me stuff I said you
know I'm racing so I you know III need
some help with this and I learned I yeah
I learned some things I mean it's you
you can learn it but then to do it is
kind of a whole nother you know they
always say in cycling like just follow
my line if I can do it you can do it
that's not true don't believe that even
to this day mountain biking my husband's
like if I can go down these rocks no I
can't because you have just a better
balance and awareness of your body
weight and it's like
you know you have to be uh yeah and
that's just time I mean that's just time
in the saddle right exactly right yeah
so it's uh yeah which I didn't have time
you know that was it was kind of one of
the issues so but I got I got a lot of
uh I did I did get a lot of miles in
with that with that messenger job and
then you know rode in every Saturday and
Sunday just with the group rides in
Santa Monica and got lost I took cabs
back from the see me ride like multiple
times I didn't know where I was and what
was weird you probably wrote by this
house I think the ride comes by here old
oh for sure no when I was driving here I
was like this is this is my training
ground for years
yeah every road up here so was there one
race that like kind of clinched it for
you where somebody noticed you and said
hey we can develop you or like how did
it how did it transpire to you then
becoming professional yeah I so it's not
a small team for a couple of years and
that team we went to US Nationals in
when I remember what year but probably
90 probably 2000 yeah yeah I think 2000
and I got for that US Nationals and that
not our first US Nationals
yeah after riding how many years at that
point no years yeah and so then that
then in the road race exactly mm-hmm
yeah I've been was in Redding California
so then then that's the national team
called and said you know come to the
training center and have some testing
and you're kind of old but you know come
anyway thanks a lot and then I did
testing and they were like oh yeah
you're old and you're not that talented
they were like the testing was just
supermart I was just I'm like I don't
have a lot of well of talent like I
recognize I'm more talented than the
next person on a bike but no I don't
have like really great lung capacity or
you know right so it wasn't like you
were someone who's just walking around
on planet earth with no idea that you
had this reputable amount of talent that
just needed to find its
no no is a lot of it's just just a lot
like a large capacity to suffer a lot I
think is really all that's in there and
because yeah so they were like uh uh you
know okay we'll take you to a few races
like you know clearly visually
disappointed on their face I could see
after the testing was over I was like oh
no this is this is a this is a one-time
ticket to we were in Chula Vista at the
training center down there but then I
started traveling with the US team and
you know was it was a darn good
domestique for a long time there and you
know I had so much to learn I mean I was
on the team with like you know real
serious badasses
I mean his women were fighting it out
for you know World Cups and and World
Championships and and Olympics and
that's who eyes on the team with uh-huh
so it's interesting that mainstream
audiences have know myself included have
very little understanding or awareness
of women's cycling like we watched the
Giro which I want to talk to you about
you know Tour de France all that kind of
stuff and we have some sense of what
it's like in the men's world but this
world of women's cycling just goes
completely unnoticed yeah for the most
part well welcome to the world real rich
yeah no I know
yeah right it's a bigger it's
symptomatic of something larger of
course but but i but i you know how many
women are in this sport and where do
they typically you know learn how to do
this yeah well so you know as you know
and everyone cycling is wildly popular
in europe and not here in the state so
when we were over traveling in europe
and racing you know there is an
awareness and there is an excitement
about and there are fans and it is
something that people recognize and
understand the women's side of the sport
you know why it's not as recognized here
as it is with the men is symptomatic of
something else like you said but you
know over in Europe I think they do
definitely a much better job of people
of the awareness of who the women are
but nonetheless it's still a very small
peloton compared
the men I think you know women in
general I the men tend to start much
younger they put their the little boys
on bikes this seems to be much much
younger and whether they want to or not
and they you know the talent ID camps
over in Europe will select these young
boys from ten eleven twelve women tend
to you know find it as an outlet in high
school or college or something or maybe
they're on the kind of a club team in
college and and so they have had you
know an entire they've gone to college
an entire education before they even
really start racing professionally is
this a completely different entry and
it's a completely different exit then
and the women definitely end up on the
top in the exit because you come out and
you you have a college degree and this
was a really fun and interesting part of
your life but you're ready for the next
adventures and you have the education
and the ability the men come out and
they are completely lost right cuz
they've been living in Belgium in a
dormitory since age 16 right and if they
made it all the way through then maybe
they've made it onto some really big
professional teams and they've done the
tour you know multiple times I mean
there's a handful of us writers that are
making it you know a good living now you
know you know Hincapie and and in tight
you know that crew but but many many
many hundreds more that their the
careers over either because they have a
horrific crash right and it just ends
right then and there or just because you
know they get a bit older what like 31
32 and then what what are they gonna do
so it ends up being a very male centric
sport in general because what do they do
they go right back into cycling their
managers their Swan years their
mechanics with their no because that's
what they know and they don't know where
else to go so that you know you just you
just see it kind of like you know cycle
itself right right yeah that's
interesting I wouldn't have thought that
so you end up on like t-mobile right
yeah right and you ride the Giro yes
yeah yeah what year was that
oh god that's probably Oh 2003 or four I
would say yeah I had to be amazing yeah
for sure
it definitely yeah I mean they still
have rules and women's cycling
to this day that are trying to change
that you can only ride a certain amount
of kilometers so I don't know what they
looks gonna happen to us like at the
well it's the same as women like they
don't have their shorter events for
women it's crazy it's it's really
getting silly at this point so I'm just
saying that because the Giro that we're
thinking of that the men do we could
clearly do but that wasn't you know his
life or course yeah different course
than just different links right we're
only allowed to do so many kilometers so
and it's 15 it was 15 days
I think it's shorter now but right the
men's is obviously three weeks 21 days
yeah you frail women we don't okay so so
you kind of take this road cycling
career essentially as far as you feel
like you can like you're at your peak
where are you at like in the peloton
you're kind of like in the middle of the
Packer there no I get a bit better than
that like I won some domestic stage
races and won some big and it's a big
single-day stage races and won some
stages as some big European races you
prove those those people wrong who are
like yeah you're right well we haven't
even gotten to the coup de Gras with
that but but all right so you have this
road cycling career and and then you
know basically what you're thinking
about retiring and yes I was about 35 at
the time and I I was um I mean quite
frankly I was just getting kind of bored
I get bored fairly easily still and I
just thought you know gosh I mean that
was just obviously way more than I had
ever imagined it ever could be I mean
wow what if what a ride that was what a
great adventure and you know it's been
nine years since I had first gotten on a
bike and I thought well that's enough
you know III think I'll see what else is
out there and I I had just won a
prologue at a major international event
in Australia and my coach at the time
said you know you have a really unique a
bill
at this you know 10 minute or so effort
output I was never really great in like
20k 40k time trials I was like always
like okay you know ninth or something
like that but it was never I would
always get well quite frankly bored and
them like oh my god we're still going I
could never do what you did oh my god
so I had this and do this this you know
there is where that natural talent lies
in that that middle-distance sort of
aerobic and anaerobic combined effort
and so he said I think you should try I
think you should try the track I think
you should try the pursuit like just
give it a go it's that you've got like a
really intense talent in this this
distance and so I did and I thought well
this is this is kind of this is kind of
cool cuz it's something different I went
to the track for the first time and was
scared out of my mind never been on a
track before no they had try to put me
on a track many years before and I was
so scared that I literally got off the
bike they continued their training and I
went and did running wind sprints out in
the parking lot because I thought well
at least I'm like training but I
couldn't wrap my head around going up on
the 45 degree banking and my tire
sticking like it just made no sense to
me still doesn't really and so it was
like this is so amazing because I am so
scared doing it I mean it just felt like
I was coming alive again on the bike all
the way through to the Olympic Games I
was petrified of riding at the top of
the track you're gonna even during even
the Olympics I remember the very last
time you so in my event you only are at
the top of the track in training so our
event is is done from a standing start
on the black line you know and you do 12
laps and you do exchanges so you fly up
there and down and that wasn't scary in
the event but just riding as you're as
you're kind of working into an effort we
call it you'll do two or three laps at
the very top of the track right so it
right next to the rail and you're going
kind of slow because you're preparing
for a huge burst right so but you can't
go too slow on the track
because you'll slide off and and you
know get pretty horrible would burn and
splinters I have splinters in my hips
from crashing and there's still they're
still there and so it doesn't feel good
so some of my teammates were you know
track track ease and and and track
sprinters even used to they used to be
and they were a bit larger and you stick
better on the track if you're larger
than if you're a bit lighter and I was
coming from Road racing so I just you
know I wasn't skinny but I just wasn't a
you know spread sprinter and so it would
scare the living daylights out of me
because they were going creepin around
the top of the track and I'm going maybe
you're not gonna slide but I am getting
ready to slide and I could feel like
sideways just just so the very last
effort we did before Olympic Games like
the day before we did a 1500 meter
effort and we finish and I come down and
my teammate says to me she's like you
never have to do that again because she
knew how bad it scared me and then and
when you're in competition tracks
there's all these other teams whirling
around so you got traffic on the
45-degree banking which just is like
yeah it's I can't even describe right
here so sorry but it's mesmerizing to
watch it's it's like this crazy ballet
and very beautiful like but for somebody
who who has no familiarity with this at
all like you do Team Pursuit
you're in a village Rome they have these
crazy banked turns that look 45 degrees
right how high up is the highest bank
it's like four storeys I guess four
stories well and how fast you have to be
going to kind of you know not fall and
when you're going the faster you're
going the more the more perpendicular
you are to the ground right I would
imagine yes like hmm I've never had a
speedometer at the on the bars of my
track bike believe it or not that's kind
of like something you like we always
kept our rsrm of our watt meter was
connected to our seat because you can't
read anything when you're in any kind of
effort on the track but it felt like you
know I mean sprinters aren't a laugh at
this because they would probably say
like five miles an hour but for me
little closer to 15 to feel safe because
I I never slid off the track because I
was going too slow because that's just
what I mean you know so yeah it's it's a
bit more of a clip than you would like
to just be doing recovery for sure
mm-hmm and although it's you know both
road racing and and track cycling you're
on a bike they're incredibly different
like your road cycling is all about you
know efficiency and how you're meeting
out your energy over an extended period
of time and there's there's you know
they're surges etc and things like that
within the context of that but in track
cycling it's about massive bursts of
power yeah it is able to maintain
gigantic watts on a gigantic gear yeah
also all the crazy strategy and tactics
that go into when you make those surges
and when you have those so you do have a
like you do have a fishin see and
economy of efficiency happening in Team
Pursuit based on the team and and what
the riders strengths and weaknesses are
and how you're going to use them to the
team's best ability like you can change
how many half-lap slap slap and a half
two laps people do you can feel that off
of the rider in front of you and
recognize that they're actually going to
take a short turn or that they might go
a bit longer which usually never happens
but that they're gonna have to peel off
in a short turn like in the in the
Olympic Games
and there's some made that you know I
will say there's a little bit of ego
connected to that like you want to be
able to do your full turn but my fourth
pull I was supposed to do one lap and I
knew that that my teammate Sarah hammer
was was um had an extra gear I could
feel it from the the the two laps before
that and I just instinctually knew I got
to get out of the way we got to get her
to the front for these last couple laps
I knew we were behind with Australia
this is this is to go to the into the
gold medal I didn't realize we were 1.7
seconds behind and that is a deficit in
team pursuit that has net nobody's ever
come back from yeah nobody ever has and
so
it was that was an instinctual and and
and my teammate behind me
Jenny Reid says I had no idea that you
were gonna pull off like you weren't
slowing and I knew I wasn't slowing and
I could hang but I knew I was just gonna
keep the same speed and I knew Sarah had
another gear so I came off get back on
and we ended up being in Australia by
eight one hundreds of a second so it was
definitely releasing that ego for the
team not at that you know that you you
had that at that level in the Olympic
Games but I have to do my full poll or
whatever but you kind of do in training
and you know it was you normally would
swing off if you're starting to die and
I knew I was and I just knew that we had
an another gear with with another rider
so anyway incredible amount of tactic
tactics and savviness and thinking and
then just subconscious thinking you get
to know each other so so so well right
you have to be so in sync with your
teammates then that's subtle like that
subtle intangible thing that you're
aware of that allowed you to make that
decision right in that moment that made
the difference yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah I mean how long do you have to ride
with your teammates before you can kind
of develop that awareness um well we'd
been on that journey together I guess
for four years I mean I had ridden with
her before that like she was she was the
person that I met her and her husband
Andy sparks at the LA track for the very
first time when I tried it when that
coach I had said and said try it so so I
had written with her for even more years
than that but but the real push to 2012
Olympics was you know we'd been out of
her for years
mhm and and just to be clear like team
pursuit is basically you and your team
there's four of you right yes so my in
2012 it would they did the women three
women three kilometres you couldn't lose
anyone now they do it just like the men
it's four women four kilometres but you
can drop someone so totally different
tactic like you see different you're
rotating who's pulling exactly yeah
so the tracks are there 250 meters so in
3 kilometers you're doing 12 laps you
know 4 kilometers you doing 16 and you
start from a dead start so track bikes
or fixed gears no brakes so you start
the starter that's taking the most load
from the start isn't a gate and then the
other people are up track being held by
a person that is acting as a starting
gate and so you're in a gear that is big
enough that when you get up to speed you
can go fast enough so it's it's it's
really it's about 800 watts of power out
of out of the starting gate which is a
gnarly way to start a race yeah I think
about it when you start a time trial you
know you start in a spinny gear a little
bit till you get up to speed so you
don't load your legs so it's this really
gnarly load the first five seconds of
the rest of lactate ya cascade from like
just blast and then you're team pursuit
like a your cadence is up to 100 like
122 right yeah yeah that's what we
averaged we yeah exactly yeah in a race
yeah that's in that in that Matt monster
Monster gear so for for track ease we we
rode 102 s at the Olympic Games which is
pretty big and what is the training like
daily basis what is the training is a
real combination of aerobic efficiency
and anaerobic power so it is very much
like that you know I compared it to the
800 meters or 15 underwriters rec track
runners so we're doing five and six hour
Road rides we're doing gnarly gym work
and we're doing really explosive track
work I mean you you know people don't
realize in three-and-a-half minutes I
mean that's that's not anaerobic you
know you need oxygen if you're going for
three minutes you know 16 seconds so
it's a combo and if you don't have that
efficiency and if you don't have that
base and you don't have that economy you
can't ever go as fast as you go and that
level if you if you don't have that set
in your system it's like the hardest
equation to solve because you have to be
incredibly proficient as an anaerobic
athlete and as an aerobic athlete I
think the 800 meters it's because you
can like if you're running the 800
meters you can't go all out
the entire time right there is some
pacing and some strategy involved with
that but you have to be a sprinter and
you have to be an endurance athlete yeah
but at that level at the Olympic level
you you are I mean I would say from our
race like you you always you always die
like you never you you that we've never
did a race that we increased or I should
say decreased our lap times you also so
you literally are building a system that
can go all-out for three minutes in 16
seconds and that training involves
longer endurance training on the road
and then also super high output on the
track right right it's just busting it
as hard as you possibly and and and
another thing that people don't realize
is how much raw strength is involved
because with the one gear and with that
big of the gear you have to have the
strength to keep that gear turning over
at 122 right so the hunt the cadence so
the fastest anyone is gonna go on a bike
is the highest cadence and the biggest
gear so a lot of people look at tracks
like they're like oh wow they're
spinning so high you know they're at 122
but you're in here you're doing that and
to keep on top of the gear as well as we
say it you have to have an incredible
amount of strength because you can't
fall off the gear because once you fall
off the gear it's over you're you're
dropped because in Road Cycling you can
you can shift if you're kind of fault
you know that feeling you're kind of
falling off the gear and is like whoa I
got to spin this out move through some
lactate right you can't recover yah and
regroup right so you can't do it on the
track right the track the the track
athletes track cycling athletes look
totally different from the road cyclists
they almost look like they're very very
thick and squat and incredibly strong I
almost look like wrestlers you know
right leo sprinters totally look like
that I mean they look like I mean it
tracks like that it is so similar to
track and field
you've got the sprinters and you've got
the middle distance and you've got the
endurance and they you know they tend to
look the part
yeah what's that crazy event
like the I don't know what it's called
the Dolly Madison or something like that
the Madison right like I still don't
even understand what that is
it's insane yeah so they sling each
other I mean you're in a team of two and
and they and you you basically rotate
laps and they use each other as a
propeller to go fast into the into the
next lap so so the person that is coming
out of the race on to the relief line
you know is swings the the next person
down in and then they race and race and
then it's yeah it's it's really it's
really fun to watch but it's really
confusing it's really hard to figure out
like I don't know what's up who's
winning who is it yeah yeah but it's
pretty easy like watching cricket right
how come you didn't do individual
pursuit I did I started that was like
2007 I did my first individual pursuit
but in 2008 Beijing Olympics was the
last time that they had individual
pursuit in the Olympic Games so then
they changed that they do this a lot in
a lot of sports where they you know they
changed the program trying to you know
get the audience excited
I mean individual pursuit is an amazing
event but watching it if you don't know
what's going on can put you to sleep
because it's just like a rider riding
around in circles
so they took the individual pursuit out
of the program and added in the for the
women women's team pursuit it was
already in for the men
and they added more parity to track
cycling so it was equal events men and
women are see so for endurance track all
they had was team pursuit and the omnium
which is yeah a whole nother
yeah all right so what year was it that
you start 2007 was your first time on
the track yes okay yeah and then you you
ascend pretty rapidly here right like
you end up winning like seven US titles
something like yeah right over the
course of the next couple years so first
race on the track what was did you win
that race like what did that what what
did that look like I did you did yeah I
was
pursuit and it was it was Nationals
actually because I I went first rate
first race on the track was Nationals
than you win yes but our our most
decorated female individual pursuit er
of all times in the United States was
injured so I will say that one minute
she launched she was helping me but so I
got a little I get a little I got a
little lucky that year but in the final
of that race like you do qualifying
rounds and then you go into the gold
medal final and in the gold medal final
at that that that track is the Home
Depot Depot Center right now StubHub
Center and they'd had X Games in there
the week before which had created this
like incredible amount of dust and
there's they hat it was like there was
like this layer of dust on the track
that was making a really slick they were
crashing a lot in the Monster energy
drinks exactly right stinky but it was
so I'm in the gate and we take off you
know the gun goes off for the the gold
medal ride and I crash immediately like
I literally take one try to take one
pedal stroke out of the gate which is a
really powerful pedal stroke right and
just slide out and fall I mean just zoom
just right underneath myself and I
didn't know enough to know because this
is literally six weeks out after the
first time I'd got on the track and I
was on it for like a week and then the
the person that was helping me you know
Andy and Sarah like you know Nationals
is in like five weeks let's just go for
it I'm like okay you know so here we are
so I slide out and this very decorated
person I'm talking about that's won
World Championships and everything at
this point had already been to an
Olympic Games she comes up to me runs up
and she's like don't worry about it
happens all the time and I'm like oh my
god Wow I'm not like oh this
happens they come out of the gate people
slide you know I take off again you get
a second rate you get a restart and I I
won and right after the race is over
I come up to her and I was like that was
the best news ever like it completely
relaxed me like okay this is normal cuz
I don't know anything about tracks like
I've never even been to an international
track race and she's like I've never
seen it that happened before in the
history of track
like wow you're like a psychologist sir
yeah she knew I needed a girl like oh no
okay we'll leave it to oh my god I can't
and then you win that's so insane
they've felt insane yeah sure it's crazy
yeah all right so fast forward to 2012
Olympic Games London you're 39 at this
point yeah 30 are you got all this
Patterson on the on the cycling team I'd
be one of the older
oh yeah a USA Olympic team in general I
would imagine right probably so yeah
yeah I am the cycling team yeah yeah I
was mm-hmm
Wow and so going into that what were the
prospects of meddling like where did you
guys fall in the pecking order
we were total underdogs I mean total I
mean so track cycling again right is not
wildly popular here in the United States
we don't know a lot about it but it is
the thing in Great Britain in Australia
in New Zealand I mean these are deep
rich track cycling countries that have
respected it for you know 100 years I
mean literally so we were up against
Giants in in this sport I mean you know
it would be like I mean literally is
like you know Jamaican bobsledders
beating the Germans or something it was
like we were major underdogs the the
book he's had assets at the very best at
fifth and we just thought maybe if it's
our best day ever there would be a
scratch of a possibility we could get a
bronze like you know there was we was
we'd never beaten the the British or the
Aussies before there there a team's we'd
beaten like there be teams whatever but
never so how did this happen oh my god
I'm still not entirely sure it was you
know it's that's the thing about sport
at that level is you you know you do it
your whole life or whatever and you
train and train and train but it's all
about delivering in that one moment on
that one day in that one month in that
one you know it's it's it's not
it's not something that is you could
ever probably repeat again or that would
have ever happened again a lot of the
really amazing Olympic moments right
that we watch that we just watch in
Pyeongchang like the the skier the girl
that had never won a World Cup or
anything about you know it's just like
we we had one of those moments we just
rode completely outside of our skin two
of us on the team Jennie Rita and myself
have never ever performed or been able
to put that output out on the track ever
in our history and we probably couldn't
have done it the next day it was it was
a moment in time that the three of us
put together we had a lot of love and a
lot of respect for each other
and there's something about team pursuit
or any really ton of team sport where
you know you're not lying up for
yourself you know there's there's this
whole other layer this whole other
beautiful layer that I loved about Team
Pursuit more than I ever loved anything
about Road where it was it wasn't about
self it was about it was about others
and it was about you better make sure
that you're showing up a hundred percent
because you know that they are yeah yeah
yeah it's like relay swimming it's like
relays in swimming or on track and field
I mean there's something really
beautiful and powerful about that and
that's what's magical about the Olympics
when yeah moments like that occur I mean
so cool yeah what is what is being an
Olympian what does that experience mean
to you I mean now it's been a couple of
years reflect back on that well you know
there's something there's something
great about being thirty nine and a half
at the Olympics and awesome well besides
that it's rare or whatever but I was a
grown woman and I was really really
hyper aware that I was at the Olympic
Games that this was not going to be an
experience I would be repeating that I
was representing my country and I
specifically got selected to go deliver
for my country and my team and and and
USA Cycling and I was able to just be
there and be super present and soak up
every single moment where I think if I
gone to the Olympics it
20 you know you're like oh this is cool
mmm awesome clothes I'm gonna be here
ten more times you know which you're not
necessarily first of all twenty year
olds right you don't know that that's
the case but it was a it was just a
magical experience for me in every way
because I allowed it to be and I I went
after it being that experience and just
I had done a ton of sport psychology
because I struggled with really big-time
nerves in track cycling but I felt like
I got there just really fully completely
mentally and emotionally present and was
able to have that full experience and so
it's almost it's almost like fairyland
when I look back on it it really is it
wouldn't mean as much to you if you were
younger and and and weren't able to like
have that presence of mind and and no
perspective right yeah either like there
was just no and I had a ton of
perspective and had almost died and you
know this was really just felt like a
complete gift that that this was even in
the realm of possibilities that I was
now experiencing this crazy when you
think about it a little nutty from like
wandering out into the middle of an
interstate to being on the podium in
London I mean it's extraordinary yeah
well that's something
thank you did you see Icarus the doctor
documentary Icarus yeah yeah what do you
think like as an Olympian you know that
now we're in the midst of you know this
conversation about state-sponsored
doping and kind of this cloud that is
hovering over these lyrics itself and as
somebody who's who is an Olympian like
and the Russians have had some doping
violations they're not gonna be invited
well I know and you had him on the
podcast I think I also I have I think a
little bit of a different view of that
movie than some other people that I've
spoken to about the movie you know if he
hadn't have been very specifically
seeking out his own systematic doping
would never have run into that doctor
and that holds that whole part of the
story would have never unfolded the
second half of the movie and that the
systematic doping and how it is is is
interesting it uncovers a lot of truths
that were not uncovered but as a
Olympian and as a clean athlete and as
someone who you know was very conscious
about being clean the movie really kind
of angers me because he was setting out
to cheat very complete full
consciousness of cheating I don't care
if it's just a grand fondo or whatever
you're gonna go to the line there's a
lot of people there that lined up in all
honesty and clean and the fact that it
didn't work gave me some pleasure but
yeah I'm not a big fan of the movie
because of that like I don't I don't I
don't love watching stories of people
vindictively dishonestly going to the
start line I don't have any respect for
that yeah I get that I get that you know
as somebody who is in a sport that has
you know a cloud over it as well
right sureties clean and and all of that
I can understand you know that emotional
response to that for sure it is it is
fascinating to see what's happened
though on the on the geopolitical stage
as a result of that second and third act
of that movie though and I think more
right will be revealed and right and
hopefully this will lead us to you know
some higher ground here yeah and I think
that's I mean that was why it was uh
that that part of it was like you know
people you've really got a good full
view of the underbelly again how you
know how it all all of the hidden
secrets and how it's all how it all
unfolded and that's how you know
unfolded in many countries that way East
Germany I mean that that's that's that's
a whole nother level what's going on
from Russian right now I mean
well I remember the East German swimmers
from 80 exactly I mean it was something
else at the time all right well let's
talk about let's talk about the diet
okay hour and a half into this the word
vegan is not on time what are they gonna
talk about the fact that she's vegan
alright so vegan athlete hopefully they
haven't tuned out yet so when did you
turn vegan why did you turn vegan you
were vegetarian prior to that yeah yeah
history here so I just was just um
hanging out in and I was at a race in
Minnesota Road race it was a stage race
and I stumbled upon a program that
showed what goes on behind closed doors
of our slaughterhouses every single day
and I felt very confused and and and of
course horrified and and all of those
feelings but I felt really confused cuz
I thought well I think this is probably
from another country because you know
our government protects its people and
that of course has to include all of our
food sources and so I thought well I'm
gonna stop eating animals tomorrow just
in case this has any validity but I
think I'm gonna go home from this race
and start doing research and find out
that this is like obviously just an
isolated incident so I stopped eating
meat the next day you know the next
morning and then of course go home to
find out a holy mother of god this is
this is systemic across all big
agriculture every animal every species
of animal every so I was that was the
beginning of my vegetarian journey and
then as I dug deeper and found out more
and looked under more hoods
there was the exposure of the egg
industry and the dairy industry and
which are really in my opinion wildly
more horrifying than the meat industry
could ever be so this was this began
what year was a 2000 like mid 2009
uh-huh
yeah so you're full-on cycling pro at
the time
did you have some trepidation about how
this was going to impact your training
yeah I I kind of did I I had I had a
coach who was a vegan which is
interesting and I had read the China
Study so I kind of heard about this and
was like oh that's interesting so I I
had had a sense that I might not
completely I wasn't gonna perish from
being a vegan like I was gonna die right
but I kind of thought this might end my
career like I didn't know that it was I
was not necessarily going to be able to
have the strength and the stamina
because where might I get my protein
right but I didn't care I thought you
know this I just knew almost instantly
that this was something that was
significantly more important than
anything I was gonna ever be
individually on a bicycle that it was so
much bigger than any Olympic Games could
ever be for me in my life or just in
general
and I was fully willing to take the risk
and and how did that play out in terms
of shifting your diet and then
monitoring how you're progressing as an
athlete well I started I mean you know
when people asked today oh gosh I you
know how do you do it it's so hard and
it's like I didn't think it was that
hard I still am just it's not that
question because first of all there's
Google you know I mean I can get like
whatever 50 years ago with something
it's like okay but it's just just I mean
it just explodes in your face it were
recipes and foods and all this and all
these interesting ways to put the foods
together and the flame
and the taste and the spices and and you
know still we have to remember that our
food our plant food our spices our herbs
are what flavor meat food
nobody's ever just you know most of the
time slapped just a piece of meat on the
grill
they have marinated it and tenderized it
and spiced it and that's plant food that
does that so when people say oh well
it's not gonna taste very good it's like
we are the food that is making your food
taste good so it's it I thought it was I
thought it was interesting I thought it
was fun like I really was like
interested in the journey of it and I
loved cooking all of the sudden which I
hadn't for all of those 37 years I just
my husband and I went out to eat six
nights a week it was like boring kitchen
I don't want to do now I'm like
interested in cooking and preparing food
and then I start to become really
interested in you know types of
nutrients that I'm putting in how I'm
feeling and then what's coming out on
the bike so I'm doing like all these
little mini experiments with myself and
then I'm going back to the drawing board
and going okay a little more of that a
little more of this you know what it was
it was just yeah it was it was fun and
cycling is a super interesting template
to explore this because it's like this
perfectly conceived contraption to
quantify human output and performance
you've got the power meter you got the
hurry monitor I mean especially on the
track it's like a data mining machine
right so there's there is no other sport
where you could just lose yourself in
graphs and data to really map out like
okay what is what's the impact of this
on this right so were you were you like
sort of paying attention to that oh my
gosh yeah yeah and I had a I am
unfortunately too tall for really
awesome aerodynamics I've got really
long legs in a short torso so I sit up
quite high and so in in track cycling
and team pursuit you have you know
exactly how many watts that you have to
put out on the front to sustain the
speed that you want to go for me it was
for hundra
74 and I know exactly but don't know
that's really high
I know exactly how many watts that I
have to put out when I am in you know
relief quote right which was closer to
340 so that's my rest
whereas may teammates when you're
shorter and more aerodynamic you have to
put out less walk walls so I had to put
out the most watts on the whole team
every time I took a poll and every time
I was in you know in line so I knew
exactly how much I had to produce and
exactly what types of foods were fueling
that and keeping that at a consistent
level if you will like consistently
being able to put out those Watts on the
front and days that I could or couldn't
and what you know what was happening it
was connecting almost everything to my
input my nutrition which before I had
just been like a zombie like I just ate
whatever was in line at the training
center like you said before which was
pretty nasty stuff and now you know it
was it was it was like it's just so
interesting to see all the different
plant foods and what would happen and
then you know everybody talks about this
but I mean for me it was really
important to be recovering because I am
thirty nine and a half and I'm in I'm
you know everybody's in a race to
recover right because we're only
damaging during training well and we're
only repairing then during rest and
that's when you get stronger you don't
get stronger in training so for me that
that was my race the recovery was my
race it's every athletes race but
especially as you're getting older and I
had started noticing that my recovery
was changing you know but before I had
gone plant-based I mean it was it was it
was deteriorating and I was like wow
this is I am NOT failing like I used to
after the six hour rides you know
meeting the same thing I'm sleeping the
same way you know so that that was a I'm
doing the Norma tech boots and all that
commotion getting massage and
chiropractic in about all of that stuff
every day all day long you're thinking
about yourself all day long
yeah it's moral to be an athlete at that
level is very self-involved that yeah it
really has to be all right so then going
plant-based you're noticing an
improvement in your ability to recover
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean that was
like in like a couple of weeks I mean
that was just so fast or I quit and I
didn't uh
to be quite honest it's something that I
connected at first I mean I don't know
it's stupid I mean that's the only thing
that had really changed right I used a
you came in from an ethical point you
aren't doing this like I'm going to use
my performance you're doing this from an
ethical perspective this is an
intolerable system and I'm opting out
I'm opting out whatever happens
athletically is gonna happen yep yep and
I and I and I hope that something good
will happen because I feel like by
opting out I'm doing good I mean I you
know then so so maybe maybe maybe
something will come from this and and it
definitely did but it was um it was it
was yeah I don't know it the other thing
that's so joyful about it is you know so
many people say when they say oh you
know it's hard it's hard to stick to or
something like that to me it's like it's
such a joy to sit down at every meal and
and you're aware that you are choosing
conscience over ease like whatever is
just there and it is so uplifting and so
fulfilling and such a empowering feeling
like I feel so strong every time I'm
slightly challenged let's say it like a
business dinner and we're like it Ruth's
Chris you know like whatever that
happens once a freaking year who cares
but everyone's worried about that
steakhouse where you know but you know
people are just people are really nice
and the last experience I had a Ruth's
Chris which wasn't that long ago they
brought in a vegan meal from a
restaurant down the street because they
knew so it's because right now you and I
aren't that quiet about it
so and the whole table was like what are
you eating that looks so delicious and
you're like well you just have your
little
dead animal over there I mean it's sake
you know it's because it's just it's
just so it's so bountiful and so
colorful and so you know is I thought
that was just great they all wanted some
I was like no I'm not sharing very
hungry
[Laughter]
when you were when you were in the
lead-up to London you said you had a
coach who was vegan I don't know if that
was your coach at that time coach of the
time that yeah I see and and so you know
it's not just you you've got these three
other women right and so are they going
well like you know you're like you're
going like what how about it really like
by the time I was with them I was
already plant-based like I had that had
happened here's the vocal aspect of what
you do is a recent development because I
don't remember hearing about this during
London why it wasn't like Oh dot see the
view no no I didn't do any social media
back then anyway it was like I didn't
even realize it was like sent no no no
it was like it was like my husband's and
I little you know he was he had gone
pescetarian by that point you know and
in he's so he was like right after
London which he did and I did and he
didn't even tell me and then like I'm
literally going to Whole Foods going to
see the fish guy like I need the fish
that you know was just clocked over the
head once and it wasn't the one I mean
this is I'm going to these links for for
my husband it's better finally he just
stopped eating them how did this fish
get here I know I was like and you have
a chain of custody no he and he was
probably biessing me but he would do
that I mean he would like you know okay
yes
we're gonna go here to this week though
clocked over the head ones that didn't
suffer at all or right here and there
the sea bass and so you make your story
like oh that's so ridiculous so
ridiculous but they didn't really yeah
it was just kind of like they just I
just ate what I ate and and you who was
freaking out was my track coach who's
like a larger kind of like chubby
version of Crocodile Dundee like he's
back country Australia
and he was like what what this is what
why why would you do that you know like
why is this a thing what I have to deal
with like it was like putting him out in
a way of so but it didn't take long for
him to like oh okay this is working I
don't you eat whatever you want wow
that's interesting yeah I mean I think
that that you know maybe what you do
gets gets unfairly lumped in with like
endurance athlete runner type people but
I think people don't appreciate or
understand the amount of power and
strength required to perform at that
sport I mean it's like massive amounts
of power like crazy amounts of strength
that you need yeah so that I mean just
to give a comparison so on the I did a
lot of inverted leg sled work because I
needed to lift move an incredible amount
of weight that I was not going to be
able to move doing squats because I
would have crushed my upper body and I
had a I had a lot of work to do in a
short period of time to get up to that
strength that we were talking about
because I'm coming from Road Cycling so
I went from being able to do about
started at like 250 pounds on the
inverted leg sled to 585 pounds times 60
reps times 5 sets because my coach had
gotten to me where we would almost be
the length of the event so the 60 reps
with 585 pounds on it would it would
take approximately yes exactly and
that's a pretty obscene amount of weight
you're 130 pound female yeah that's
crazy all on plants right unbelievable
so when people come up to you and
they're like you know well do you think
you would have done better on a paleo
diet or do you know like what kind of
crazy questions you have to field right
to defend your yeah probably the same
ones you do I mean you know it's like I
think I mean it changes them longer
you're in it right there's I in this
movement or speaking about this you know
people people ask people are asking
better questions than they were before
but I think it's also just people are
becoming a little bit more educated and
more aware and and and you know but you
know it's it's it's kind of still all
the same stuff right now where they just
people really don't
and not only protein but they don't
understand iron they don't understand
b12 they don't even understand what b12
is that it's a bacteria and you know you
where you can get it from they think
animals make b12 so there's there's just
a lot of misconceptions out there about
the different nutrients that that that
they think that you need from the myth
that we've been told and lied to about
our whole lives that you can only get
that from animal flesh so it's just
those you know do you have were you
taking supplements or do you have to be
eschew those because fear of like yeah I
know that was always a scary thing
because in my in my road career I was
taking more supplements I probably are
definitely more than I needed to being
completely plant-based I was taking a
liquid b12 that my doctor would
prescribe and I would pick up the
pharmacy just so that I knew it was not
didn't have a lot of fillers in it right
when you just get them at the store they
have a lot of fillers so I was taking
the b12 and I was taking a Whole Foods
plant-based iron because I I did my best
when my iron levels were higher than
they would naturally run mm-hmm and when
my ferritin levels were higher and my
hemoglobin levels were higher so I would
cycle this whole food plant-based iron
which I could easily get from food but
it would be like you know a large trough
of teenagers easier to control exactly
exactly but it was still you know mega
food so it was still the plant and
that's it just those two you know
protein powders no BCAAs no none of the
amino acid none of that stuff I didn't
bought no way no I would do some plant
protein every once in a while just
because you get you know tired of you
have to I I mean I was taking in 5,000
calories a day and sometimes more and so
you know with ultra endurance you just
get tired of eating you know I don't
really do protein shakes anymore but I
did back then because it was just like I
just want to drink something I think I'm
gonna die if I have to eat again because
you just yeah
all right so 2012 you win the silver
medal you're doing it
plant-based but you weren't a mouthpiece
for this movement so between then and
now you've made this decision to be a
vocal advocate for these issues right
what inspired that and like how do you
think of yourself as a as a mouthpiece
for these issues that we care about yeah
well you know I I didn't when it came
back from London I didn't know anything
I didn't know there was a I didn't know
there isn't this is a theme with you
tipping over on the track I'm doing the
aids ride on my on my mountain bike
happening I didn't I had no idea there
was a vegan movement I had no idea there
was an animal rights movement I didn't
know about you yet I didn't know I knew
absolutely nothing I'm still to the
point where I I'm not sharing anything
because I don't think there's anyone
that cares and the the moment happened
when my husband came home one day from
doing some shopping he'd been to native
foods and he saw a little cute group of
people meeting he it happened to be
Mercy for Animals he got a flyer and
brought it home it was like look there's
like people that talk about what you
talked about and I picked up the phone
and called mercy for animals in Santa
Monica and got a hold of Ari solemn and
I'm like you guys like did you like what
how do you what are you doing so he said
come up come up and see us let's have
lunch and that was the beginning of
recognizing that anybody talks about
this and that Minh that people listen to
them and actually care and are creating
a pretty large movement of people that
give a crap well it's amazing as
somebody who not so long ago didn't even
know existed you're having PSAs airing
during the Olympics and you've created
this compassionate Champs movement like
tell me what that's all about
so I'm learning more and more every day
but when I started compassion champs it
was a it was really kind of more out of
a desire to meld together compassion and
strength I felt like there was you know
nobody really that
that was having a real conversation
about being able to be caring and
compassionate and and loving and
empathetic but also strong and fierce
and badass and you know those those two
just weren't coming together as a group
of people so that that's that's where it
was kind of born out of I'm learning
more and more as I am traversing this
movement and reading more research and
understanding more from being a part of
the game-changers film which we can talk
about that's you know people and and and
just from my own experience sadly and
and really disappointing to me is by and
large people don't care about the
animals they just don't they just they
don't care about the suffering they
don't want to know about it they don't
want to hear they don't want you to show
them they don't definitely don't want
you to talk about it and they really
don't want you to talk about it when
you're all eating but people do care
about their health and they do care
about their performance not just athlete
you know athletic performance people
just care about their general
performance and being better in their
life right a lot of the people that
you've had on here so the conversation
that I'm having is is changing a bit
more I think it's I'm almost feeling
more like a undercover animal activist
because it's at the core of what I care
about the most
it's the least effective way to change
people's minds right the way to impact
people is is by appealing to what
interests them not what interests you
right such a bummer and I think that you
know the athlete plays a very
interesting role in this movement
because what they're able to do with
their body speaks louder than the words
that come out of many a doctor's mouth
many an activist mouth because when
someone sees you with a silver medal on
sees you on a podium or sees you on that
village room kicking ass it's like wow
how does that how does that
person do that I want to know more about
who that person is and what what
inspires them and what fuels them and
telling that story is a way to impact
hearts and minds that I think is
different and important you know and
that's why I think you know this game
changers movie that you're a part of is
gonna be a really big deal like I
haven't seen it yet I've seen the
trailer but I know it's making a splash
you were at Sundance you just got back
from the Berlin Film Festival tell me
what it was like to you know see that
movie be part of that movie and to
participate in in in screening it before
audiences for the first time yeah it was
just a wild pleasure and honor right I
just feel like you know we're kind of at
a tipping point of this movement you
know we're not anywhere near like the
large percent of the population heating
plant base but I feel like I'm
definitely having outside of the
movement right we've take ourselves
outside to really recognize but those
conversations are at a much higher level
than they used to be people are at least
aware now that they've decided that
that's for them or not
maybe not but screening the film at at
Sundance and at the Berlin Holly Inn in
Berlin which was the international
premiere it was so many different types
of people asking all different types of
questions you know it was that's what I
loved about it it was like a wide
variety of of questions that not just
your typical like oh where are you
getting your protein well they cover
that in the film so maybe that's why
they weren't asking that but and
people's reaction to it was its Sundance
it really really caught me off guard and
by surprise normally we're used to
people saying oh okay this is
interesting plant-based okay I think I
might try a recipe or I might try
meatless Mondays or I'm gonna try this
on thus lots of people we do the QA
after the film right there's about 15 of
us there the doctors and the Emeth leets
I'm the only female because the other
two females it's a
very much very kind of a bro heavy
totally it's very focused on young men
because they are the ones that are
resistant to change
as far as eating meat and the meat myth
so the street females in the film and
the other two are still competing so is
the only female there so I just got this
rush of women you know standing in line
to talk about this and every single one
says I'm starting today what do I do for
dinner
somebody else comes up and says I'm
going back to the condo and I'm supposed
to cook for 10 people and I have chicken
in the refrigerator and I can't serve
them that it's you know it's disease
don't you know they would she would pick
out different parts of the movie that
she had learned about all of the
gnarliness of chicken and I can't in my
right mind
serve them that well what if what you
know I don't know what I'm gonna do and
I'm thinking oh my god oh my god no cook
the chicken let's start tomorrow you
know it's like oh my gosh it was in a
completely different type of panic all
most of these people just just so moved
by what they learned and so moved by the
health aspect that they were everyone
starting tomorrow and so I was like wow
guys we gotta really be ready for this
cuz nobody knew that was gonna be the
reaction yeah you better have your
answer like chambered yeah yeah yeah it
was a feed them when the inspiration as
is at its peak right exactly exactly
yeah yeah so we yeah what was that what
was the response in Berlin how is it
different
um it was it was gosh I people are a
little bit more subdued there you know I
just said the germs are also questioners
they're much yeah yeah so we got I mean
we yeah we got there's a part in the
film where it kind of goes into tobacco
industry and kind of how they were
eventually exposed even after there was
you know 700 studies that says smoking
kills you but they had you know kind of
kept them all quiet and the PR firm
exponent that is known for hiding big
tobacco hiding a lot of chemicals that
are in
different things that we lotions and
things we put on our skin and are now
spinning big agriculture so that was
very that was an interesting topic in
Berlin like a lot of people brought that
what are we gonna do about exponent mmm
that's not okay you know so that that
was a little bit more askance of what
you were trying to go for well yeah but
I mean if you'll you'll see it it kind
of it at least helps people to
understand why all of this how all of
this marketing is working this meat myth
is working in the machine that's behind
big agriculture and the spin that every
time something comes out like what we're
doing was switched for good if we get
big enough which we better and I hope we
will there'll be some type of exponent
whether it's them or someone else doing
a quick spin forward big dairies so that
that is it's it's a pretty integral part
of the film for people to understand why
they're being told this myth like where
it's coming from and and and how much
money is behind that myth so but but but
Germany as a whole and is especially
Berlin I mean Berlin is known as the
vegan capital of Europe so you know it
was really people with a very open minds
to at the film you know yeah we were
talking before the podcast about how
amazing Berlin is for vegan food they
have be gone so full vegan supermarket
we're like they have that we don't have
that here I'm real crush I just couldn't
get all over myself
well so what is there a release plan for
this movie like we they have the
distributor lineup yeah well yeah I mean
they don't know yet either so the the
the cool thing is that they're the
distributors are fighting for it so
they're in a great place a great space
to be in
I assume in within the next month
they'll hopefully make that decision of
who they're gonna go with I mean their
their goal is very much eyeballs on the
film and and not that they don't have a
monetary goal their goal is for you know
1 billion people to see the film which
is lofty goal but it's it's
you know I it's certainly possible if
not maybe probable so they if you if you
keep up with the website you know that
that'll that'll tell game changers movie
comm will tell when it's similar release
because I mean everybody is seems you
know good thing seems to be dying to see
it but I think it'll do some more fit
film festivals too before yeah so we'll
we'll see alright so we got to wrap this
up but I have one final question we're
two hours we're good you have this
competitive nature you have retired from
cycling where are you gonna channel this
this this energy into this movement yes
or there's there's no question in in in
my mind that I will do this until the
day I die it's it it it fills every
piece of my bursting heart with so much
joy and and and and need and fulfillment
and that this is this is revealing the
secrets behind this is is very similar
to back in the day with tobacco I feel
such a such an inherent deep need to
share truth with people like if if it's
not if they're not if they're not being
told the truth somebody has to tell them
the truth somebody has to you know
uncover and and if I can use the
Olympian thing or the Olympics thing
that I you know did and fought really
hard for because you're right people
people are interested in what in you
know Olympian eats or what it an
Olympian does I mean it's you know
that's part of this you know PSA with
the with the seven Olympians it's like
nobody's going oh god no stupid
Olympians put them in the corner you
know people just kind of are inherently
like go team
and so that platform will will hopefully
hopefully allow us to reveal and uncover
these untruths that that people have
been
been told their whole lives from animal
agriculture all the way to all the
different diseases that the seven top
diseases that we're dying from in this
country people are just consuming
incredible amounts of dairy while
they're fighting prostate cancer you
know incredible amounts of dairy while
they're fighting over Ian's cancer it's
insane and so it's it's it's it's the
only thing besides my relationship with
my husband that I care the most about
it's it's it's everything to me well
it's beautiful and it's exciting times
you know I think the awareness is
getting out there and there is a there
is a you know a growing interest and
receptivity right to these ideas that I
think is only gonna build and and your
role in all of that is is prominent and
growing so it's awesome to see one final
thing if you'll indulge me so I think it
would be great to kind of end this with
leaving a few thoughts for somebody
who's listening to this who perhaps it
is suffering from an eating disorder or
is stuck in the cycle of you know a
pattern that they can't see themselves
through so if there is there a lifeline
that you could throw to that person or
or something I could think about or do
that could perhaps be helpful well
there's a couple of things I think that
when you're deep into the disorder you
definitely don't feel like there's ever
any way out and that's especially true
with eating disorders because you have
to continue to eat right you can't just
be like okay no more no more drugs no
more alcohol
I felt so isolated by that and just
letting them know that there truly is a
way out once an anorexic not always an
anorexic it's it's it's not the same as
it is it is it might be or how many
alcoholics look at it and and for their
own recovery
there there is freedom on the other side
there really is a pathway whichever path
way you choose to have freedom from it
so many eating disorder sufferers that I
met that's the one thing that they just
don't really believe is true and it is
there really is freedom and I think the
other thing is that most most eating
disorder sufferers are fairly type-a and
they most that I've met want to
contribute to society I mean they have a
kind of a yearning kind of a desire if
you let this disease run its course and
you die from it you're not going to be
able to do anything you're not going to
be able to have an impact on the world
and you're not going to be able to do
anything for the greater good and you're
definitely not going to be able to do
anything healthfully for the greater
good while you're sick so allow that to
be your bright guiding and shining light
out of this that was a big part of it
for me is is recognizing that I can't do
anything if I'm dead you know so let
that come to the top of your heart and
let that guide you there is there is a
way out and you you can't do anything
for the world if you're dead yeah
beautifully put
and and raise your hand and make
yourself known and find help find that
person that you feel comfortable talking
to that you can confide in and I think
that's an important first step in
breaking that cycle of denial and that
that prison that keeps you stuck yeah
yeah so thank you thank you
yeah this was awesome Dottie you're an
inspiration I really appreciate your
time and your testimony yeah as well
it's powerful and I wish you well and
keep doing what you're doing I feel like
we're saying goodbye forever so we come
back and talk to you some more tomorrow
cool so if you want to connect with dot
c @ c Bausch
Twitter and Instagram compassion champs
vegan Olympian on its division Olympian
oh that's right yeah well it's funny I
type your name in but then it
automatically pulls up vegan Olympian so
that I know yeah that is weird right we
got like six months ago awesome
and it's compassion champs calm yeah
compassion - champs doctor okay I got
work and you have your own personal
website - right yeah Kazi box yeah USA
okay
dr. pot dot see bow she usa.com yes okay
you got it
all right well yeah please do come back
and talk to me again this was great
thanks all right Thank You ppreciate
Lance